please be seated
provost coatsworth executive vice
president Dirk's faculty colleagues
alumni doctoral candidates and
especially their mothers
families and friends good afternoon and
welcome to convocation for PhD
candidates in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences I thank you all for
coming to celebrate the accomplishments
of our PhD candidates we honor today a
superb group that on commencement is
coming Wednesday will join the ranks of
our close to thirty eight thousand
alumni and will embark on academic or
professional careers around the world
equally important we honor today the
families and friends of our candidates
who have endured with them the grueling
marathon of the PhD thank you for being
so supportive and above all so very
patient
I would ask all doctoral candidates to
rise and applaud those family members
and friends who have helped them be here
today
today an outstanding PhD candidate and a
distinguished alumnus who is also a
member of the faculty will address the
assembly in turn the PhD candidates
remarks will be offered by mr. abhishek
Ganguly a doctoral candidate in the
Department of English and comparative
literature mr. abhishek Ganguly
successfully defended his dissertation
in January 27th entitled the poetics and
politics of translation in contemporary
drama 1962 1990s professor gayatri
chakravorty Spivak and martin buechner
directed his dissertation other members
of the defense committee were professors
Brent Edwards GRE visvanathan and Bruce
Robbins mr. Ganguli received a BA with
honors in 1998 from presidency college
university of calcutta and an MA in two
thousand in english and linguistics from
Jawaharlal Nehru University in New Delhi
he earned a second MA and an MPhil from
Columbia in 2003 and 2005 respectively
and will earn the PhD on Wednesday mr.
Ganguli was awarded the marjorie hoped
nicholson fellowship the melon summer
research fellowship the sign Sainsbury
student support grant from Columbia's
Arts Initiative and a seed grant from
sir I the new media initiative from the
Center for the Study of developing
societies in Delhi for studying
contemporary urban musical performances
in Calcutta as a PhD student he
instructed in the undergraduate writing
program as a teaching assistant in the
multiculturalism joint seminar in the
Institute for comparative literature and
society and Columbia Law School he has
lectured at the university of delhi and
bryant university he has presented his
research at a dozen international
professional conferences mr. Ganguli is
an assistant professor of English at the
Rhode Island School of Design mr.
Ganguli
provas cosworth executive vice president
darks Dean Alonso members of the faculty
administration and staff family friends
and fellow graduates it is an
extraordinary privilege to represent the
graduating class of 2012 Thank You Dina
Lanza for inviting me to speak at the
phd convocation this year thank you in
associate dean beatrice Therrien for
walking me through this on behalf of the
graduating class I would like to begin
by thanking the professors who have
taught us challenged us and guided us
through all these years I would like to
thank my advisor guy to talk about this
be back for a tremendous support and for
being an extraordinarily generous mentor
along the way I also want to thank the
family and friends of all of today's
graduates was faith in our ambitions and
abilities have undoubtedly been vital to
our successful completion of this
journey of five six seven or more years
studying at this great University in
this extraordinary city when I walked
onto campus for the first time on the
bright fall morning almost nine years
ago I thought I knew in my head the
exact topic i was going to research down
to working with lee ography and at least
two alternative titles for my as yet
unborn dissertation it could have been
the pressure of entering the department
English and comparative literature for
me it could have been the pressure of
entering the department that had
pioneered my fields of study
post-colonial studies and the still
somewhat oddly named Anglophone
literature's it could have been the
excitement of joining a brilliant
academic community that or its diversity
and globality lightly but confidently
situated as it was in the heart of New
York City next to vibrant Harlem
whatever it was it somehow felt like the
right thing to do at that time today
looking back it seems an endearing
moment of intellectual naivety but it
was also the first instance of what was
to become a consistent marker of my
academic life and I don't know if I
share this with in your view but an
obsessive compulsive desire to over
prepare / prepare for presentations for
conferences for publications and now for
teaching little wonder then that exactly
one semester
three graduate semanas later I realized
that that first recitation had to wait
my ideas my professors assured me were
very much worth pursuing but they still
contained reading list size holes that
he had to be covered over yet what was
more troubling was perhaps the
realization that I had interesting
thoughts running off in many more
directions than I had initially
suspected not all of that has ended up
well but it has been one exhilarating
journey intellectual journey that has
taken me all over campus two courses in
anthropology and sociology architecture
and film studies even to Barnard and the
law school and in one intrepid instance
to the cafeteria the CUNY grad center
where David Harvey taught his free open
class on reading Marx's capital every
Friday evening and in between coffee
fuelled all-nighters and standing room
only guest lectures one day I ended up
in a seminar that was being taught by
Edward side I did not realize then that
it was going to be the last class
professor side would ever teach before
his untimely death I'll never forget the
day when after we had collectively
failed to recognize the significance of
a particular sartorial detail mentioned
in Gustav Lopez well-known
nineteenth-century novel sentimental
education and we were a smart bunch my
cohort in English department professor
side after we had failed to answer him
he wistfully wondered aloud who lets you
guys into graduate school these days so
Thank You Columbia for keeping it real
inside an outside of class rooms inside
outside and Beyond lectures and seminars
office hours and conferences and at the
numerous life-sustaining cafes bars food
carts and restaurants in this
neighborhood I witness that quality of
the real a certain grittiness translate
into a spirit of critical thinking and
intellectual skepticism cynicism even as
we made lifelong friends and
commiserated with comrades in arms today
as we formally take leave of the
mothership I sincerely hope that that
fortitude will end your that enlighten
skepticism will continue to flourish not
just when we are faced with a simple
pressure to conform but more important
when we find ourselves within
complicated ethical and political double
binds we're acting in an either/or
manner
would have disastrous consequences let
me share with you how this relates to my
own work in my dissertation I tried to
put forward a relationship between
translation and the formation of
collectivity I focused on a range of
contemporary plays from around the world
to demonstrate the relationship the
notion of translation I was working with
inevitably went beyond its conventional
understanding as simply a communicative
act or inter lingual transfer and ended
up looking like that familiar double
bind everything is translatable nothing
is translatable translation is necessary
translation is impossible while keeping
this double by invisible I attempted to
extend the domain of translation by
arguing that it is the very substance of
literary form and dramatic technique
translations as figured translation has
figured in these texts also emerged to
be a political instrument to count
politically we need to form a group but
every group necessarily leave someone
out even as translation and the theater
helps form collectivities who translates
for the excluded I believe it is
increasingly important for us to
remember this question as we seek to
place our research and scholarship in
the real world the world of the illegal
immigrant and the working poor and on
the best days the world where we hope to
build our lives and communities from and
around there is a disturbing crisis in
higher education in the United States of
this moment we graduate saturday
standing closest to perhaps only one
aspect of it the increasingly bleak
prospect of secure and decently paid
academic employment at the end of a
stint in graduate school spent in
obtaining the highest qualification in
the field we are extremely happy for
those of us who have found the jobs they
wanted and thought they deserved at the
end of their PhDs and I must say I'm
very lucky to be one of them and I wish
all the very best from all of us to
those of us who were yet to do so on the
one hand there is a rising proportion of
adjuncts in the profession probably most
acute in the humanities and the social
sciences the talk of an impending crisis
in academic publishing the increasingly
higher research productivity needed for
the shrinking number of entry-level
academic positions and on the other hand
the alarming rate at which the costs of
attending college are outstripping the
growth of real income making it
increasingly unaffordable for most
people our future students all of these
should concern us directly and I'm sure
they already
do for many if not all of us as we step
out of graduate school but the question
who translates for the excluded allows
us to imagine the ripple effect of this
crisis beyond Columbia in the corners of
our world where the global community
must also exclude it is the cautious
optimism and intellectual skepticism the
hallmark of my Columbia education as I
mentioned earlier that makes me recon
these stark facts on what is without
doubt an extremely proud and celebratory
moment for all of us as a farmer and
therefore forever New Yorker I repeat
that winter slogan remember the neediest
upon this warm day in me even as I
extend again a big thank you to our
professors and a huge fellow station and
good luck wish to all my fellow funny
cap wearers who have accomplished that
one tremendous thing successfully
completed a PhD degree now doctors let's
go ahead and have a blast just as soon
as we can thank
Thank You mr. Ganguli now I would like
to present the Dean's Award for
distinguished achievement to a PhD
alumnus in the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences to professor Eric Foner the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
holds in highest regard intellectual
inquiry that excerpt a profound impact
not only in academia for the larger
world as well today we honor you Eric
Foner an alumnus of the graduate school
whose historical scholarship has
enhanced our understanding of our nation
and ourselves a native of New York City
you first came to Columbia as an
undergraduate graduating summa laude
from Columbia University in 1963 as a
recipient of the prestigious Khaled
fellowship you earned a second
bachelor's degree at oriel college at
the University of Oxford then returned
to Columbia to complete your doctorate
under the supervision of the renowned
historian Richard Hofstadter over the
past four decades your work has explored
America's intellectual political and
social landscapes in such publications
as reconstruction America's unfinished
revolution 1863 through 77 which
received the Bancroft price department
price and the Los Angeles Times Book
Award the story of freedom a masterful
examination of the nation's most
cherished idea from the colonial period
to the late 20th century and your most
recent book the fiery trial Abraham
Lincoln and American slavery which was
awarded the bankrupt price the Pulitzer
Prize for history and the lincoln price
you have exemplified service to your
discipline with ten years as president
of the Organization of American
Historians the american historical
association and the Society of American
Historians you have also helped to shape
popular understanding of American
history curating prize-winning
exhibitions on the Civil War and
reconstruction and consulting on
historical landmark and museums operated
by the National Park Service as well as
historical exhibits at this disney world
and disneyland as a DeWitt Clinton
professor of history
lumbia he have mentored a number of
talented graduate students and received
both a great teachers award from the
Society of Columbia graduates and the
university's presidential award for
outstanding teaching in recognition of
your exceptional career and for being a
model of what a Columbia graduate
student can accomplish the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences is delighted
to present you Eric Foner with a Dean's
Award for distinguished achievement
the doctor'll address will be offered by
a professor Foner thank you very much
Dean Alonzo Dean Alonzo Provost
cotesworth executive vice president
Dirk's colleagues and of course doctoral
candidates and your families and friends
it's a privilege to address you on this
occasion I've been invited to speak at a
point of transition in my own career I
have just completed my last year of
full-time teaching at Columbia although
I will be teaching part-time for the
next four years before riding off into
the sunset this moment brings back
memories of my own experience as a
student and some of the teachers who
shaped my life as a historian the finest
teacher I have ever known was my father
Jack phoner deprived of his livelihood
during the McCarthy era because of his
political beliefs he made his living by
freelance lecturing listening to his
lectures I came to appreciate how
present concerns can be illuminated by
the study of the past how the
depredations of McCarthyism recalled the
days of the Alien and Sedition Acts how
the civil rights movement needed to be
viewed in light of the struggles of
black and white abolitionists a century
before and how in the brutal suppression
of the philippine movement for
independence at the turn of the 20th
century something omitted from textbooks
at that time could be found the
antecedents of the American intervention
in Vietnam this was history as
collective memory and understanding
forging a living link between the past
and the present beginning in 1959 I was
an undergraduate and then graduate
student here of course Columbia was a
far different institution than it is
today the college was all male and
essentially all white the Department of
History had no black faculty member and
only one woman Nina Garcia and a
specialist on the history of Armenia the
curriculum was resident resolutely
traditional no social history women's
history
in history but on its chosen terrain the
history of American politics diplomacy
and intellectual life the education was
unrivaled I received my PhD in 1969 in
keeping with the spirit of the times I
did not attend the commencement ceremony
although I have a vague recollection
that it may not have taken place at all
since in that year as well as in
nineteen sixty eight and nineteen
seventy the University shut down early
because of student demonstrations I
finally I fondly recall some of the
teachers I encountered here and the
lessons I learned from them there was
James P shenton a flamboyant lecturer
who conveyed his passion for the Civil
War era so powerfully that the period
has remained the focus of my own
scholarship ever since and there was my
doctor'll supervisor at richard
hofstadter renowned for his penetrating
intellect and sparkling literary style
his advice about the craft of writing
make war on the verb to be and ninety
percent of writing is rewriting those
remain Maxim's we should all still try
to live by I have often reflected on how
working with Hofstadter shaped my own
career my work has centered on the
history of political ideas and the
relationship between politics and
society the answers I've given differ
markedly from his but these are
Hofstadter questions it is customary on
occasions like this to wish the
graduates well as of course I do and to
call upon you to pursue your individual
dreams while also helping to improve the
world we live in but I want to place on
your responsibilities as well in
whatever area you apply your talents and
whatever walk of life you find yourself
I want to urge you to dedicate
yourselves to keeping alive your
Columbia education most cherished
inheritance respect for the life of the
mind in today's society this is not an
easy task in the last generation the
values of the market have come to
permeate every aspect of our society the
notion that the public good may be
measured in other than economic terms
has pretty much been abandoned the
philosopher William James once wrote
that an hour spent communing with nature
must be considered a worthless hour of
life when measured by the usual
standards of commercial value the same
can be said for an hour contemplating a
work of art or reading a work of history
as a result as my colleague Andrew
Delbanco observes in his new book
college arguments for higher education
today are almost always couched in
economic terms having more educated
people as good for the economy or for
the social advancement of individuals
unfortunately as del banco points out
this outlook helps account for the fact
that literature history philosophy and
the arts subjects that do not seem to
increase economic productivity are on
the way on their way to becoming
stepchildren at all levels of education
perhaps not at Columbia but at most
public schools and institutions of
higher learning let me illustrate my
point with one small episode in his
generous introduction dean alonso
neglected to mention the real highlight
of my career my appearance on The
Colbert Report afterwards one student
remarked professor you made as well
retire now because you will never top
that you may wonder does a guest get
paid to appear with Colbert you do not
but you do receive a hundred dollar
certificate that can be donated to a
charity via an online network so I
looked at the website for worthy causes
in New York City i alighted upon a
posting from an elementary school music
teacher in the Bronx she was not able to
conduct classes for her students because
the school could not afford sheet music
so I donated my hundred dollars to
enable her to buy the sheet music this
is pathetic the United States spends
more money on weaponry than all other
countries combined but we cannot afford
sheet music for public school students
what does this tell us about our
priorities shortly before his
death in 1970 Newsweek published an
interview with Richard Hofstadter it was
a melancholy reflection on a society
confronting what he called a crisis of
the Spirit young people said Hofstadter
had no sense of vocation no aspirations
for the future he rejected the young
radical stance of moral indignation as a
kind of elitism on the part of those who
did not have to face the day-to-day task
of earning a living but he acknowledged
the real roots of their alienation he
said you have a major urban crisis you
have the question of race and you have a
cruel and unnecessary war ultimately he
went on American society not just its
children had to change four decades
later we again face a crisis not just a
crisis of the economy but another crisis
of the spirit we live in a world where
scientific knowledge is subordinated to
political and religious dogma where
intellect and expertise are denigrated
as elitist where demands proliferate
that history be taught as an exercise in
national self-congratulation not
critical self-examination this is the
frame of mind that divides the world and
America itself into the forces of good
and the forces of evil and sees every
dissenting view as disloyalty today
Hofstadter's call for Americans to
reorient our value seems more relevant
than ever and the study of history
although it may not contribute much to
economic productivity may offer
assistance many years ago Charles
Francis Adams the president of the
american historical association noted
that quote the historical point of view
is an important point of view for only
when approached historically can any
issue be understood in its manifold
relations with a complex civilization
the economical outlook he went on vital
as it unquestionably often is comes much
lower in the scale these observations
are as apropos now is in 1900 when adams
spoke for the study of history instills
the very qualities so lacking among
policymakers and more broadly today the
value of critical inquiry
of subjecting all beliefs to the test of
reason and experience of questioning
dogmas whether political religious or
economic that demand uniformity of
thought the historical frame of mind the
foundation of this University's idea of
a liberal education may assist Americans
and candidly facing our problems and
reordering our priorities so that in the
future Columbia's values and those of
the nation may once again coincide
congratulations again to the graduates
and thank you very much for listening
Thank You professor Coleman I now have
the pleasure of introducing miss Angela
Jia a PhD student in patho biology and
molecular medicine and the president of
G sac the Graduate Student Advisory
Council she will present the faculty
mentoring award to Professor Diane von
in the department of sociology and
professor Eleanor sterling in the
department of ecology evolution and
environmental biology miss Tia thank you
good afternoon today I have the distinct
privilege of representing the graduate
student body in awarding the faculty
membership award to two most deserving
candidates the faculty membership award
is given every year by the students to
faculty who have gone above and beyond
the call of duty to assist guide and
nurture their students along their path
of academic and professional development
this award recognizes outstanding
faculty members and shows appreciation
for the exceptional support they have
provided to a student they truly
exemplify excellence in graduate
education in their roles as advisor
mentor advocate and friend I am honored
to present the first award to Diane von
professor in the Department of Sociology
her students ranging from current PhD
candidates to assistant professors
described her as a tireless and
outstanding advisor and inspiration to
graduate students extremely accessible
and giving mentor and never hottie or
arrogant about her opinions despite her
prolific presence in sociological
thought today professor Vaughn's humble
openness and sincere consistent
intellectual engagement testifies not
only to her integrity as a researcher
but also to her standing as a true role
model for aspiring researchers and
professional social scientists on behalf
of all graduate students Thank You
professor lon
the second award is to Eleanor sterling
adjunct professor in the department of
ecology evolution and environmental
biology despite working full-time as the
director of the American Museum of
Natural History Center for biodiversity
and conservation her students both at
Columbia and overseas praised that she
is constantly available that truly not a
student in the department has remained
untouched by her tremendous generosity
of time advice and career support
professor sterling helped found the
iii-b department and has worked
tirelessly to improve it since its
inception she has tremendous integrity
and advocates for better mentorship of
graduate students throughout the
department her students described her as
the critical motivational force at all
key junctures in their PhD journeys it
is my honor to present the second award
to Professor sterling Thank You
professor
thank you Miss Tia and congratulations
to professor Vaughan and Sterling bravas
clothes worth will now present the
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching two three current PhD student
teaching assistants the students who
will receive today's presidential
teaching awards were selected from many
nominations by a committee that included
both faculty and graduate students
robust coatsworth would you please come
forward there are three PhD students
were receiving the award today Carlos
Montes gal done in the Department of
Economics and Julie called Angela Kolb
in the Department of English and
comparative literature and Joseph whoo
in the Department of Chemical
Engineering Carlos Montes caldo
in just a few short years you have
proven yourself to be a skilled and
dynamic teacher of economics imparting
to your students a deep understanding of
the ways that rigorous analysis can shed
light on the world around us your
creativity and clarity have earned the
enduring appreciation and admiration of
your students who have flocked through
recitations and discussion sections they
extol the extraordinary quality and
breadth of instructional materials you
have prepared and praise your
responsiveness at all hours of the day
or night you have a bright future ahead
of us both scholar and educator Columbia
is proud to recognize your
accomplishments by awarding you the 22
2012 presidential award for outstanding
teaching by a graduate student Angelique
old in the Department of English and
comparative literature
as a teacher of university writing
literature humanities and courses and
literary studies you teach the ways in
which precise attention combined with
passion can open literary texts unto the
world that surrounds them you inspire
your students through your gift for
language your trademark enthusiasm and
your boundless generosity your students
describe you as a talented classroom
presence who is devoted to the
intellectual discourse you seek to
foster and is constantly willing to
extend pedagogy outside the classroom
you have also served as a valuable
mentor to your fellow writing
instructors you are a literary scholar
whose teaching is engaging erudite and
genuinely humane with pride we join your
students in praising your excellence as
an educator with the 2012 presidential
award for outstanding teaching by a
graduate student
and finally Joseph woo in the Department
of Chemical Engineering teaching the
fundamentals of chemical engineering is
no easy task yet your students praise
you as a remarkable instructor capable
of simplifying the most difficult
concepts your students celebrate your
remarkable ability to reveal and
highlight the core principles at the
heart of the engineering problems you
present to them they value the
supportive learning environment you
create and your patient determination
that every student in your class will
succeed your teaching is informed in
equal measure by empathy and technical
skill in recognition of your exemplary
service and professional promise the
university is pleased to confer upon you
the 2012 presidential award for
outstanding teaching by a graduate
student
we now arrive at the central point of
the ceremony the presentation of the
doctoral candidates we ask you to come
forth as we call your name in
recognition of your individual
accomplishments professor and the talker
of the ph.d program and communications
will read the names of the PhD
candidates as we approach the podium
you
from anthropologie Maury Sylvia belen
Nadia alone John Horne Carter and
Katherine Holman from applied
mathematics I Neil Raj material science
and engineering and Theresa and Fazio
Applied Physics Daisuke shiraki apam
Applied Physics Maria coming at Scott
ofir goth own luck apam material science
and engineering team or davis g go Sean
Lawrence bury our history and
archaeology page Stevens knocks joseph i
lo teresa marie Harris
Jessica basciano Kim Lee Chi moynihan
Amy Inge Carolyn York your keys Patrick
Crowley Olivia Shannon Powell Sonya
dreamer Jeffrey Alexander Miller
astronomy andreas fitting biochemistry
and molecular physics biophysics Daphne
Christina and a stuck-on estas ities of
gosti biochemistry and molecular
biophysics pallav kasuri biological
sciences a shock oil gender Linda you
Christina a Doyle Christine and Denny
Zita Peter lenders ambar eschar salam
benedetta marine le re biomedical
engineering siren fumi rat Brenda Chen
Molly la reflects Minh a VTOL Mendelsohn
Bronte sha yao shang tongue biomedical
informatics Nina had Freddy do all
Jonathan William keeling wei zhang by
aesthetics wha-ho chen nan shisha
business min wang Roger Douglas
Letterman dumb lagunas Ganesh aha Ron
Coan mullah ver SI r hee-haw rovi Xiao
Qing Ming Connelly
ravindra vote Elise austry BR neat or
facin cell biology Noreen kibriya
Nicholas Dennis Carbone chemical
engineering leha's are being serene
jameel fish eat on chemical physics Jai
jawan Chen joining lee chemistry li wen
chang jung hwan lingo Wang Benjamin
Isaac dash Margaret Mary elva crow
Severn Thomas nebulae Jeffrey rensdale
Lancaster rohitha sriman among civil
engineering and engineering mechanics
Arturo Umberto Montoya badri hero your
been lush in ski Pablo pre Otto Mona
Moneo t-mo Neos CEO pang Duke jin-joo
classics Howard shaohao Chen Patrick
O'Farrell Gotye
Ian Helene Communications Holly Johnson
philip k computer science j Woolley
Joshua rush David clogger elson he law
Becker Malik ben selim young bo song
maritsa Johnson Mitchell Joseph I o Shah
Morris Blake Shaw Bert Kwang Kumiko Oh
No mica lamellar East Asian languages
and cultures jahmene Kim takia he know
Adam Paul Bronson Nathan Powell shocky
he told me yoshio robert james tuck
earth and environmental engineering kun
yilin Christina Karim Perry do Mackenzie
primera no comb way do jing li ashley
elizabeth Schuler Jennifer hailey levy
Zachary tesslar Amelia's duker ecology
evolution and environmental biology
Elizabeth Stevens Nichols Marcia macedo
Megan Micheline McGinty economics
William Walker Hanlon Ryan amateur hour
david robert d reamer Joshua elliot
green field arigato Tokyo Tapia heritage
Stein Grimm's daughter Demetria score
sorrows Juliana Logan ova Elizabeth gene
acres william reed walker wilfredo Elora
limb jr. Sebastian Rondo och ins a
kimchi Maria and Herman maressa and
Herman
hey Toshi she gioca Marcos llamar anaka
guma Leslie Jean Turner Christine Pai
Chi Alexander Fraser McQuoid belly you
are study us uh stood a static highly
yow Asamoah OHS oh oh so answer taka
kazoo hon Rio electrical engineering
segi Hong Sardar koja mountain see me on
really really off Matthew Lee gently
Johnston John Barbosa Vicente jr. gido
haha movic Kevin shoe
english and comparative literature
elizabeth andrews macarthur sharon and
fulton jennifer marie James Abigail
Catherine Joseph Christine Varnado
abhishek Ganguly min bangee Sena butta
lazy Environmental Health Sciences Allen
carpenter just epidemiology Veronica
Maya freising ER Samantha Garber's
Russell McBride Nikki Patricia palmetto
Monica hoga augurs elska French and
romance philology an almiri kirua
genetics and development reply Aurora
Germanic languages on yes Kelly Guto
look at Co Sarah Pantera
Julian Nordmann history Megan Doherty
Jennifer Elise camp tummy Mary Catherine
weibull Carlos Galvez pinya James chapel
daniel scott cason Samir Adam mughelli
Robert Marshall near jr. Ty Stein Jones
Michael Woods words operations research
Tim Hughley soon min coke Netzer hottie
but Latin American and Iberian cultures
Mario Elie valero mathematics adam
joshua Jacob
Alice rizzardo svetlana ivanova petkova
Harold Martin Sultan mechanical
engineering panayiotis Spiros cuts its
let's eat US Marine silliman air stop
anurag mater microbiology immunology and
infection sujatha gora nathin Middle
East South Asian and African Studies
Audrey Trish key music melissa gonzalez
christie k Riggs mark Seto lu wang
andrew lawrence Harry near Victoria took
ova nursing Pamela Blythe de Cordova and
Margaret navara Andrew Bartlett Phillips
nutritional and mattel metabolic biology
Kelly Ruggles chuchin Liz Chang Mariana
lool abdullahi Colleen Renee rezac
Roxanne do TIA
diana d'ambrosio path pathobiology and
molecular medicine Celia Denise crime
tonight Kong some oxen pharmacology and
molecular signaling to heal you Jay
Rebello philosophy bo caramel shaw
michael robert stevenson physics Aaron
Richard unja ronnie alexander vincent
penson robert do Mullen gym Guillaume
plant cheer jingly you Joe Jinjo Xiao
Yun Jin Trevor David Nathaniel R own
political science Martin Jorge Adonis
Michael Charles beckley volleying jus me
lon vaish enough Laura Beth paler
Kelly Theresa Raider Diane Roberta fun
Stein wray co huong Quinn Mulroy David
Joseph O'Connell Patrice Howard jung
kyung kim psychology Jared Xavier Munson
ellenburg Lauren event atlas Julianne
Spicer Jason Thomas fuel Brian Thomas
Denny Jang bong park Michelle one
religion Abigail Sue's inclusion Slavic
languages Emma k Lieber social work
kenneth terrell jones
rumiko kaka Shima Akashi David Harris
socio medical socio Medical Sciences
Maria Dolce natividad Deborah Jane pelto
TC comparative international and
international education i'm rishabh
aquel reyes TC philosophy and education
Martha more Crowley TC mathematics
education Diane Rosemarie TC politics
and education Jonathan Sullivan Kirko TC
counseling psychology Chekov a Pamela
Hall TC clinical psychology George
Coolidge knits burg TC English education
julilah reporter TC science education
tan Xena taher he see comparative and
international education Pamela Torres
Newkirk TC history and education Sharon
gay Pearson TZ measurement and
evaluation Sarandos Sonia googa
TC comparative and international
education Mahama Abbas Mel Mela susana
Martinez restrepo economics in education
in TC Izumi yamasaki mathematics science
of Technology Bernice beer amala theater
Timothy Earl euchre urban planning James
John Timothy Connolly Deltora president
of the gsas Alumni Board will now speak
to you about the Alumni Association of
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
mr. sir Thank You Dean Alonzo Provost
cotesworth vice president Dirk's
distinguished faculty alumni friends and
our most honored participants here this
afternoon our graduates thank you very
much for giving me a few minutes to
address you on behalf of the Alumni
Association of the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences and its board of
directors as well as nearly 40,000 gsas
alumni worldwide I offer our graduates a
hearty congratulations on this momentous
occasion and milestone in your career I
also welcome you to the next phase of
your relationship with the graduate
school and the university that is as
newly minted automatic members of the
gsas Alumni Association you thought you
were through you're just beginning our
alumni association was formed over 50
years ago its mission is relatively
simple and redefined that is to
establish a nurturer community of alumni
foster the engagement of alumni with
academic and institutional initiatives
of the graduate school support the
interests and needs of current gsas
students
and assist the Dean in perpetuating and
enhancing the reputation and prestige of
gsas in furtherance of our mission our
board and its various committees meet
several times a year and we have held
rather well attended annual meetings
here on campus at which we have
showcased interesting and provocative
faculty speakers alumni as well as
graduate students who have proudly
shared their ongoing work we're a
particularly committed group of alumni
who pride ourselves on having some fun
together along with our fearless leader
Dean Alonso we have sponsored a variety
of events including career panels and
alumni socials and many of us have
mentored students as they look forward
to careers including those outside the
academic world we have also helped
publicize and support graduate school
activities such as departmental reunions
concerts lectures and it goes on and of
course we work with and support the
activities of the overarching columbia
alumni association we have hosted and
sponsored activities in New York
Washington Chicago Los Angeles San
Francisco and other cities we even spent
a weekend a few years ago at biosphere
two among the ants in Oracle Arizona and
I along with other board members have
met with gsas alums all around the world
in London Paris Geneva beijing and hong
kong how do we keep in touch through
various ways including mailings the gsas
alumni newsletter called superscript and
generally via our gsas alumni website we
have one gsas columbia.edu backslash
alumni many of us also follow graduate
school activities by logging on to the
newsletter for gsas students with which
I'm sure you're familiar namely 109 low
but our success depends in part on our
newest fellow alums we need to know how
to be in touch with you so your correct
email address or physical address is
important and we want to hear from you
we want you to contribute
to our newsletter if not articles please
feel free to share announcements of
publications and professional
achievements where you are give us your
ideas on how we can further our mission
come to our events be in touch get
involved and if you don't heed my advice
and you become a rather sleepy alum okay
here's a voluntary disclosure from a
lawyer I was a rather sleepy alum for 20
years and if somebody from gsas comes
knocking on your door like they did mine
and let you know how much you've been
missing at your number one alma mater
you may just find yourself as the next
president of the gsas Alumni Association
giving a welcome at convocation
congratulations again thank you and
welcome new members of gsas or narcissus
Thank You mr. sir and now my closing
remarks to the graduating class we're
engaged today in one of the most solemn
moments of academic life in a grand
setting surrounded by those dearest to
us yet I would encourage you to examine
it for the ritual that it is with its
trappings customs and the very silly
hats some of you may ask rightfully
whether there are times in which it
would be best to suspend true critical
scrutiny and bask unabashedly in the joy
of the moment life is continually
presenting us with such moments of
unalloyed bliss or sorrow for that
matter finding love the birth of a child
the death of someone near to us and it
behooves us to give ourselves totally to
those moments if we're going to have a
claim to being fully alive it is the
experience of plenitude that can
overwhelm you when least expected as it
does mrs. Dalloway at one moment in the
eponymous novel and I quote it was a
splendid morning to like the poles of a
perfect heart life struck straight
through the streets what she loved was
this here now in front of her having
lived in Westminster how many years now
over twenty one feels even in the midst
of traffic or walking at night a
particular hush or solemnity an
indescribable pause a suspense before
Big Ben strikes their out it boomed
first a warning musical than the our
irrevocable the leaden circles is solved
in the air such food we are thought
Clarissa Dalloway crossing victoria
street for heaven only knows why one
loves life so how one sees it so making
it up building it around one tumbling it
creating it every moment of fresh but
the truest frumps the most dejected of
miseries sitting on doorsteps do the
same they love life in people's eyes in
the swing tramp and trudge the bellow
and the uproar the triumph and the
jingle and the strange high singing of
some airplane overhead was what she
loved life London this very moment in
May and of course but this is precisely
the solace and the comfort that you have
waved in the long apprenticeship that
has taken you to this afternoon because
regardless of the discipline in which
you will receive your doctoral degree
this coming Wednesday what you have
learned is not merely a way of asking
questions about particular objects but
the very discipline of asking questions
itself hence you should be proud of and
faithful to what you have learned here
but the discipline of asking questions
requires that you not be so proud and so
faithful that you be unable to critique
the very education that you have
acquired in this institution in order to
be continually open to the new you must
be able to take your distance from the
presumed necessity of what you have
learned here to challenge the very
things that define you as belonging to
your institutional origin to entertain
at every turn the possibility of
self-imposed exile from your academic
home graduate programs do not
necessarily prepare us well for the
inevitability of intellectual change in
our academic life this is not the case
because of narrowness of mind or
conservatism but simply because what we
learned in graduate school was a current
face of the discipline that we joined
the horizon of expectations conventions
and rewards toward which we worked in
our long apprenticeship in graduate
school and the kind of intellectual
arguments and analytical moves that we
saw our professors perform in class or
in their work and which we assumed as
templates this is what we reflect when
we say as if it were an explanation that
someone has a PhD in anthropology from
the University of Chicago say or a
master's in Germanic studies from
Columbia or a doctoral degree in physics
from Princeton in each of our fields we
know precisely what that X
pression means because graduate programs
have distinct profiles a kind of family
resemblance or air that they imprint on
their students and which arises from the
particular questions and interpretive
strategies that the faculty of each of
those programs convey to their students
as the appropriate ones to entertain
knowledge is disciplinary by definition
and we both receive it and recreate it
within the optics of that disciplinary
yet we must train ourselves to think
outside those confines not just because
knowledge is increasingly multi and
interdisciplinary but because above all
what we aim to teach you was the
acquisition of the vexing habit of
continually challenging everything you
espouse the kind of openness to the new
that I propose and the vigilance
required for it to manifest itself in
your scholarly life will be learned
every single day all the daily moments
in which your capacity to confront
change or to become the agent of change
will be tested not only or even
principally by what is new and
unforeseen but even more forcefully and
dangerously by what is customary and
what will be expected of you it will be
as such moments that you will renew the
legitimacy of the degree that you're
about to receive and the trust of this
institution will deposit in you by
granting it at such moments it will be
worth remembering that you will not
confer this degree just because you
could ask certain questions but so you
would ask questions critically dog
Dudley and unsparingly even if perhaps
especially if the one not spared is
yourself we are immersed nowadays in a
radical technological turning point that
whether we agree with it or not has
already changed thoroughly who and what
we are how we do our work and even how
we read the symptoms of this new
circumstance whether related to the
commodification of all experience that
characterizes globalization or to what
may seem to
as the narcissism of the digital social
networks or to the transformation of
reading into a sort of skimming are
however not a passing phenomenon they
are here to stay and no amount of
railing against them will change that
fact in the face of that reality we must
first be honest with ourselves and
further and most especially be generous
with our students who do not even have
the experience of another way of being
and sees expressing disappointment about
the deficiencies and limitations of
their novel ways of knowing our students
know other things possess different
skills and make other kinds of
connections with the information that
they possess and with the world this
openness to the new is represented by
our students performance of their selves
to as better student performance of
their selves is going to be I think the
single most substantial challenge of
scholars and pedagogues that we will all
be facing in the near future the
humanistic Shibboleth an unexamined life
is not worth living may not be relevant
anymore when one's life is minutely
excruciating Lee and routinely displayed
for conspicuous examination in Facebook
Twitter and Vimeo it may very well be
that we will have to contend with a new
understanding of the self not based on
concepts and metaphors of depth or
uniqueness one that will be articulated
not in a vertical but in a horizontal
understanding of the subject such a
transformation will have profound
implications for ourselves for our
students and for the ways in which we
will understand or professional work
henceforth but most important you will
have to come to terms with these issues
using the critical and intellectual
tools that you have acquired in this
institution and take them to their
ultimate consequences even if the kind
of scholar that you were trained to be
or that you thought you wouldn't be may
no longer be tenable as propositions for
the gift that you
amia gradual dedication has given you is
to be able to entertain in your mind the
most radical thought experiment what if
things were otherwise than what they are
what if you were not how you think you
are and then to reimagine the world anew
we your professors and mentors in the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences are
certain that you will take meticulous
care of this exacting gift of the
cultivation of the otherwise go forth
prosper and prevail make us and your
relatives and friends prouder still of
you than we are today with the candidate
stands who may give them a final round
of applause please
you are invited to a reception
immediately following the ceremony on
Hamilton gone under the tent I ask
friends and families to wait until after
the faculty and the candidates have
walked to the Hamilton sent before
exiting to your right at the exit
closest to me to Hamilton lawn for the
champagne reception thank you